People are looking for conspiracies everywhere,
man.
I keep hearing them now about Anthony Bordain that Bordain was gonna expose some
child pedophile ring and that's why the suicide at them.
It's fucking stupid man.
Without going down fully on that road.
There is one odd thing about the board thing,
which is just a few weeks ago,
didn't he tweet some odd thing about having the,
the,
he's met the Hillary Clinton like machine or something and he was talking about,
no,
I'll tell you exactly what he was talking about.
The same people that Harvey Weinstein used would that were,
um,
Israeli,
what does it black cube or some shit.
See what you find the tweet because it,
he's,
he was basically saying that,
uh,
Donald Trump's people use the same people that Harvey Weinstein used.
So Israeli intelligence group too.
You know,
there was something that Harvey had done to his victims where he was trying to
silence them by scaring them with these,
uh,
these,
you know,
Israeli mercenary type folks.
Point being,
don't go down that conspiracy theorists now what he was doing with me,
he was just saying,
guys just standing like he's got,
he had some crazy thing with his girlfriend when he was like fully invested in
her battle with Harvey Weinstein.
You know?
So that's what he tweeted about.
But it was,
it's like they would kill him for that.
Like that's so fucking stupid.
Yeah.
Well what about Ronan Farrow?
What about all the people that wrote the story?
What about all the people that are accusing him of rape?
Like that's the guy's going broke to do that.
People don't understand that Harvey Weinstein is business is going bankrupt.
He's fucked.
He's going to jail.
Like the walls are caving in.
He doesn't even have,
his business isn't anymore.
I ran a mercenary to go kill a chef.
I mean,
this is fucking stupid.
This is stupid thinking.
And you know,
look,
it's not,
it's not that it's impossible for someone who would want to hire someone to kill
someone.
But I don't think that's what happened.
I think he killed himself and I think it's a terrible,
terrible tragedy.
And I think it's really disrespectful to have all these dumb speculative ideas
because there's sport in conspiracies.
It's a sport.
It's a game.
There's a hobby that people have.
And looking to fucking,
I'm looking for the truth,
Bro.
I'm looking at fucking close the gaps and feel this.
It's,
this is what it is,
man.
It's the Illuminati.
The second you think you got it right here.
Um,
okay.
Here it is.
Hold on,
scroll up.
I'm in no way here.
Liquin I've been on the receiving end of her operatives wrath and it ain't fun.
Right?
And that's from about a month ago.
Those operatives,
Oh,
here we go.
Now you're going to fill some gaps for me.
Her operatives,
Raf.
Okay.
I don't know.
But the thing is,
Hillary Clinton was before the track,
before the,
the scandal happened.
There's a lot of photos of Hillary Clinton hanging out with Weinstein.
Oprah hanging out with them out.
Everybody cuddle and Meryl Streep,
Meryl Streep,
cuddling up with them.
Like the whole thing is there's people that are complicit for sure.
And in one way or another.
So after everything you just said and knowing that Joanne's plays that game a
little bit,
would you have him on again if I had them on again,
that would be the first thing.
And we'll talk about,
you know,
I'm,
I've been friends with Alex since 1998 I've known him for a long time.
Yeah.
I don't think he's a bad guy,
but I think he's very wrong.
But a lot of things,
he's very misguided about a lot of things and I think he loves conspiracies.
There is a bunch of people in this country that loved to make,
they will have to connect the dots and find conspiracies in fucking everything.
Everything that there is and sometimes the right and Alex has been right.
Definitely.
It's been right about a bunch of things.
He was right about the World Trade Organization particular about when they were
using agent provocateurs to disrupt protests and make them violent protests by
smashing windows.
And he documented all of it how these people were.
Um,
none of them were arrested,
they were all,
they all went to a one safe house and then negotiated with the police.
And then they were released.
They all had military,
um,
military issue footwear,
like he's got all these,
the,
these documents from people that worked inside either police or law enforcement
that say that there is a standard practice and this has existed for a long time.
And when you have peaceful protests and you can't do anything about it,
the best way to do something about is to take that peaceful protest and turn it
non peaceful.
Yeah.
The way you do that,
you have these guys wear masks,
they go in,
they pretend that one of the protesters,
they start smashing windows,
flipping over cars and then you move the cops it and then they shut the protest
down.
So you essentially shut the peaceful protesters down by introducing non peaceful
people.
And you,
these are military operatives,
these are people that are working for the government or working for whoever the
fuck decides to pull the trigger on this.
And this is real.
This is happening.